[Musique]
alors que michel sardou est actuellement
en représentation pour la pièce
n'écoutez pas mesdames il a est
interrogé par le journal la nouvelle
république et s'est exprimé sur les
nombreuses accusations de racisme qui
lui ont souvent collé à la peau c'était
la mode à l'époque j'étais le seul à
aborder des sujets avoir des points de
vue différents des autres chanteurs de
ma génération évidemment j'étais le
premier à attaquer si l'artiste a
souvent été attaqué sur ce sujet c'est
dû aux paroles de certaines de ses
chansons comme dans le temps des
colonies ou encore le rire du sergent
des chansons qui pour lui ne représente
en rien ses opinions je n'ai jamais été
aussi de ma vie ni réa que je m'en fous
mes chansons sont des chansons et ne
sont que deux chansons ça n'a pas plus
d'importance que ça voilà de quoi vous
rassurer pour vos prochaines soirées
karaoké alors est ce que vous comprenez
que michel sardou et vous lui remettez
les voilà les choses bien sûr je
comprends qu'il met les choses au point
je ne dis pas qu'il est raciste mais il
a chanté des chansons qui le sont
racistes et puis ce qu'il avait dit sur
la famille de johnny hallyday c'était
très violent alors quand il avait elle
dit mais moi ça me choque et ça c'est
typiquement le genre de chanson que lui
chantait au second degré et qu'on a pris
au premier degré quand il chante les
colonies qui se moque des gens qui vont
mal se comporter là bas et ça a été pris
comme il a passé
les seigneurs du racisme dans un livre
dont tu veux dire le livre raciste parce
qu'un personnage qu'on décrit qui est
raciste mais c'est n'importe quoi c'est
dangereux va
il faut écouter il a aussi refusé oui
c'est vrai que j'y le procès en racisme
c'est insupportable et tu peux pas juger
aujourd'hui en 2021 les chansons d'il ya
30 40 50 ans à ce moment là vous voulez
je retire le week-end
mais non mais voilà donc c'est juste
insupportable et il faut toujours qu'il
justifie parce que c'est un chanteur de
droite justement et donc forcément à
l'époque droite et même encore
aujourd'hui droite ces fachos on avait
juste insupportable donc il faut arrêter
voilà ce révisionnisme des chansons là
c'est vous le dire guillet non mais la
même chose il faut arrêter de parler des
boîtes de nuit toi non
effectivement il a dit ou écrit des
choses il ya 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans 30 ans
qui aujourd'hui serait problématique
mais je trouve ça très malhonnête de
prendre des propos des paroles les
ressortir trente ans après de dire cette
personne est raciste journalistique mans
c'est inexact de faire ça c'est
malhonnête mais michel canton michel
sardou cent à la fédé émission il a été
auteur extraordinaire c'est c'est le
plus grand chanteur koné connu en match
je regrette qu'ils soient arrêtés mais
je comprends qu'ils qu'ils aient terminé
au sommet non je crois que c'est un faux
procès qu'on lui qu'on lui fait bon le
france c'était le france si les ricains
n'étaient pas là c'était aussi c'était
sur des chansons qui étaient polémique
mais je trouve que ça un procès qui n'a
aucun intérêt tout cas ça la salle la
salle a blessé puisqu'il a voulu revenir
là dessus ces grandes chansons tous à
paris